[Music]
welcome
to the iron lords podcast
hello everyone and welcome to the iron
lords podcast
my name is pete also known as now though
here to give you
a little first look at xing from mass
creation
they are a very small polish company
that has given us a key
to review and also to give you guys a
little bit of a first look at
so um why don't we go right into it so
i'm gonna go first into the
uh the graphics of the game uh normally
i talk about gameplay first but i have
such a long list i figured
let's change it up a little bit so um
the graphics of the game
have are very very uh very simplistic
but they're simplistic in a way where
the art style of it is amazing
and very very clean so the animations
are working
so perfectly well fluid the moving
from the left to right the combat
between the individuals even the
collisions between
individuals all of that looks very very
clean cut
and very very well done now
i was very very nervous about this uh
this game at first but
then when we went and we actually saw it
at pax east
uh 2020 i was actually i was amazed
and i loved the look and the feel and
the movement and everything about it
so it kind of cleanly worked out so i'm
very i'm very happy with the with how
the
the graphics and the other art and
animations were for that
now for the replay value as you would
normally think of as one of those
side-scrolling combat type games uh they
they're always endless because you never
know
exactly how the combat is going to end
up uh you don't know exactly how things
are going to be
uh but the thing that was very very
interesting about the the
this game is that you also have the
ability to go back and do challenges
now the challenge is uh i tried one
and it was way harder than i thought it
was so it
actually gave a little bit more of a
replay value for that because
you're going to consistently try to go
back you're going to want to try to do
better and you're trying to
try to do more and more things now the
other thing about it is
that you end up getting unlocks to
other pieces of gear and armor so
throughout that whole entire time you're
going through you're getting these
medallions
and the medallions are going to be used
to unlock
more and more pieces of gear clothing
and things like that
now the the big thing about it is the
gameplay
and what makes me so
happy about the gameplay is so many
different things
i can't even tell you so i'm gonna try
to uh
try to go through it really really uh
kind of uh summarizing them so
so because i want you guys to go pick up
this game i want you guys to give it a
try
now um the game is about
your a handful your your four ninjas
essentially and you
are going through uh to get back
this one specific item that has been
stolen uh that is not a spoiler you
learn it within the first
30 seconds of the uh hitting the accept
button
so you it's not a spoiler so you end up
going through this process
of going through the game now you think
with a game like this it's going to be
very very repetitive
but it's not what was really really
unique about this game
is you have
directional attacks now what i mean by
directional attacks is
it means you can slash your weapon up
high middle or low
you can jump up in the air you can slash
down
you can do combo attacks you can do
many different things with your ninja
that makes it a lot more unique
than just the standard hack and slash
type game that you're gonna go through
so you have to actually think and plan
uh
of what you're gonna do when people
attack you you can
block the attacks you can parry the
attacks
so it's not just an easy you know like i
said side scrolling just
slash and go like you would for the old
type of x-men game or the ninja turtle
game
that you got when you play in the
arcades when you were younger but
you just would you have to actually take
a second and think okay
how are we going to attack this how is
it going to go now
what makes it even more complicated is
that you have those bosses
now you're thinking oh it's just a
regular boss it's not it's not too big a
deal
well i'll get back to what the first
boss looked like
but later on after you start killing the
the bosses the mini bosses they end up
starting to appear
in the actual fights so you know you're
going to be sitting there and you're
going to be you know
fighting off some minions and then the
next thing you know you're going to see
this big
uh brute just walking in and you're like
oh man now i got to kill him too
so you have all of these little elements
that are going to start
you know grouping together to make it
even more and more
complicated to play now going back to
the first boss
what made this boss super unique is that
it had a puzzle involved now a little
earlier
in that first stage you end up
encountering a puzzle
involving some lights uh i have a small
little thing in the video if you take a
look
uh throughout you'll see it but you end
up having to take the beams of light
and then ending up having to to uh
shoot it into a certain direction uh
using using your weapon
and for instance you can use that on the
boss fight to blind them
so you can hit them a little more and it
kind of was effective but not
super effective until you realize that
the when the boss eats the wrong type of
minion
and i'll get back and i'll get into that
in a second when he eats the wrong
minion
you can do even more damage to that
furnace cornea so
how are you asking about that minion
what was special about that
the minions have multiple there's
multiple different classifications of
them
you have your regular damaged one you
have your your your brute
you have your your flying ones and you
have so many but
there's one that is an elemental type
which ends up
shooting uh lightning bolts so you end
up killing that
you can pick up an orb and then you can
have a lightning bolt and then you can
just be shooting lightning bolts when
you're slashing your weapons
hitting the guy from across the room and
doing massive amounts of damage
now the damage ended up being able to
hurt those people so that you can
end up you know killing them now normal
side scrollers
you have stuff they're very very you're
going to want to do standards
there's nothing really different about
them
other than like small little clips of
you know storyline
well this game has storyline
inside of storyline just like you were
going through and then you'd have those
extra achievements um to do uh
you also have these cut scenes so you
can walk up and you'd be able to
communicate with with people that which
there is a cut that i put a cutscene in
the video for you guys to see
of you being able to communicate with a
bunch of people behind a wall
so you have all of this to give you more
in-depth information about the
characters
to make you feel more invested in the
combat in the game
which i really like because i like
feeling invested i like feeling
you know wanting to complete it and
wanting to go through it and that's
you know that's what i'm planning on
doing so
all the gameplay was super unique i
really really really enjoyed it
and i liked it a lot so uh like i was
telling you before you got the puzzle
thank you very much for seeing and
watching this video hit the like and
subscribe button
and we have the iron lords podcast on
sunday
midday if you're going to go ahead and
look at that and
make sure you guys are checking out all
your gaming needs on lords of gaming.net
where we
have our movie reviews game reviews and
news articles
so go ahead and check them out i'm pete
also known as now though
here to give you your first look for
shang
thank you very much
oh i should jump through him
i can't believe that they don't have us
i should have waited until you eat that
guy
eat them
oh i'm gonna die oh i can just change
over
and get full health on it who
dashed a little too early there
got him
whoa
no man i i'm so behind on video content
that i have to
write up
so
i'm still behind on video content right
now that i got to pick up so
and the guys from uh mass creation
um they're the ones that ended up giving
me
the keys so i wanted to do right by them
because the game came out yesterday
what baloney is that
oh my god
oh
let's get right to the ass kick
oh my god
i can't touch this
up
this guy non-stop
the stupidest things
like the worse
yes
it's a challenge area
i can like solo normal
dude would you go ellie or enhance
[Music]
[Music]
your face
wow
i was blocking
leave it to the professional did you
miss me
i can't get him up
did you miss me
don't want to do this
that was one way to do it
this is really annoying these guys are
really really hard
oh my god
shhh
let's get right to the ass kitchen
what
leave it to the professional
get out of here
arrows backwards
come on
is
you want something done
come on
oh my god
that this is
you